greetings from podcast Ville it's
Wednesday the 29th the [__] April we
did it [__] kick this
[__] muley
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah you [__] did it
congratulations April 29th to 2020 you
did it you just did 45 days out of a 60
day [__] turn yeah let's congratulate
yourselves you did something you never
thought you'd [__] do you just did 60
days so next time
the judge said 60 days you're like well
Joey I've been home since March 15 yeah
45 days 15 days for good behavior so
they give you 45 days little [__] you
think you're dealing with you
accomplished it
you [__] did it six weeks ago you
thought you sat there what am I gonna do
I'm gonna lose this I'm gonna lose that
look you're still here don't get me
wrong some of us have problems because
on the way out of jail they're gonna
grab this buy this shirt and go you got
15 more days California for one in New
York is extended their [__] thing
till June 1st so you [__] on
the way out the guy grab your buddy's
shirt annoy you [__] [__] slap a
woman in 1984 you want with 30 days for
that get in that [__] hole but for
right now you guys you did your 45 days
the worst part of this thing is over
where you at where you are you in jail
are you [__] sucking dick for [__]
money are you jumping up and down no
you're still the same person you are all
that fear and anxiety all the thoughts
about money there's no debtors prison we
did it we just did a 60-day bit how
[__] happy and why I'm over here
smoking a joint like a [__] doctor I
can't believe I survived I wouldn't
survive in prison you got holiday weeds
yet there's not after two weeks I got a
lawman down the corner need some company
you don't say I think I'm out they
kicked him out of the nursing home he's
got monies covered free he's looking to
talk to the little boys in the afternoon
I told him I drop you off a little hat
with a propeller just sort of his lap
and talk about the birds and the bees
levy you want but all jokes aside look
at that we're here and I know some years
got your unemployment check somebody's
got your stimulus check
he's got dick and you're in a bad
position and you know I [__]
sympathizer I've been there I've slept
in a [__] rocketship and this is the
exciting part is getting ourselves out
of that you guys know the last couple of
weeks I've been a little bit under the
[__] weather got no reasonable idea
I'm an old [__] man this thing could
take over am an old man that's a fat
[__] I'm a covert candidate before I
went for a walk today I swear to God
minding my own business I got my iPod
I'm listening to Soundgarden
Superunknown I got to speak this I'm I'm
just walking I usually take a walk down
to the Main Street I hope you turn then
I mix into a park and I walk home just
and every day I take a little longer
route every day I take a little bit
longer an extra block and that's how you
build your endurance they shouldn't even
know my leg hurts or whatever some
listen to the music I'm getting into
[__] spoon man the whole deal I'm
coming around a turn and who walks in
front of me this chick that chubby again
I think I've nothing against people
ain't got nothing as chubby chicks but
you know you work Oh Villa you know I'm
sorry in a future called Villa why are
you walking in my path now I'm breathing
your fat little cells I don't [__]
want it because they're you know like
the same thing I don't want you
breathing my fat [__] cold food cells
if I'm walking in front stagger stagger
I see people doing that a lot it's it's
a it's our natural instinct there's some
of us that are attracted to other people
and there's some of us that naturally
and we push away
we're introverted and we don't want to
be close to people by no means I'm one
of those people I live in both areas
I live in both areas I'm having anxiety
I'm panicking I don't like people close
to me but you know if I'm having a good
time we're gonna have a party yeah you
want people close to you but in these
times they're telling you don't even get
close like it's six feet and even then
I'm worried yeah some people are losing
their mind heaps in fights online people
say some people are taking it seriously
and some are like aren't and like then
people is causing issues you're taking
away people's livelihoods yeah okay I
didn't expect this to be good children
this grunt listen this runs down the
line to being a child
my child has our days me and my wife do
everything we can in our power to keep a
laughing giggling smiling you know why I
become a principal of a school yeah just
set up a meeting with her and a little
girl friends New Jersey and they're
riding bikes and they're bringing things
they could do from far away from each
other and the wives are together and
they got masks on and they're 10 feet
away my wife just called me before I
came in and at least the kid is out and
she gets to see other kids yeah well
about that today I think was the New
York Times or something and have like a
lot of people are just abandoning school
they're just not doing it a lot of kids
aren't going it which is a lot of kids
she's in the first grade that's crazy
my mom made me do it they would have
made you do but maybe a parent listen I
know I understand systems doing is
adequate we're helping her around it
yeah you know we work with her around
that last night I had to read three
books so I'm trying my hardest to know
what do you have to do if like you're
one of the people who actually has to go
to work and then your kids are home this
is the life that people are experiencing
yeah no this is the life that people
experiencing this is gonna change our
lives forever Blake who gives a [__] for
right now we did 60 days in the pen yeah
somebody is a sprung loose Oklahoma
Georgia go out there coughing up have a
good [__] time you know take a chance
come on biz dude that's my motto here go
breathe on the hook and see what they'll
see what your odds are but to the other
young ones take care yourself
it's a everybody has different needs in
different situations I'm not the one to
tell you what to do or what not to do it
if you don't feel you should wear a mask
today we have no guests
it's Lee and I we've been around each
other for the last seven years and the
door is open I'm not wearing a mask I
don't know if you know guys knowing how
hard it is to sit here and do a podcast
with a mask on for a [__] hour never
sucked a [__] death [__] that's
what your mouth tastes like after an
hour doing a podcast or the [__] mask
on so starting Monday I'm doing a new
series it's still the church but I'm
just interviewing my childhood [__]
friends I'm going back and interviewing
three of
my childhood friends to start this thing
over again through a different
perspective I can't get guests like this
and I mean people contact me to be on
this show and I tell them to go [__]
themselves how can I call something they
expect them to come down here with the
situation how bad with you feel somebody
came to your house and got a little
[__] sick you wouldn't feel too
[__] happy or some people were
calling you to Kovac did you know sevens
of guy that had Colvin I swear to God
now I know this guy personally from the
Denver he's a comic great friend of mine
I love him to death
he was walking past something he saw
them [__] with doing testing the lady
asked him if he wanted to test this
[__] walks over gives him a test he's
healthy as a [__] ox and they tell him
he's got Coleman so he runs home he's
been home for 14 days on the 15 days he
prepares an invite and he puts it on
Facebook on how to party free booze free
food come on over you should have seen
people decline point just learnt decline
it people tell him to go [__] himself he
just had Co vid how can they have a
party you know I mean oh no it's
hysterical what you see you know I have
been trying to stay off line as much as
possible I'd do my morning postings and
I get the [__] out of there because
between the TV and the [__] the
internet they're gonna kill you guys
guys I was feeling a you know I had to
fear cut then going on and then on top
of that I had the extra stress and I
know for a fact that nothing will kill
you like stress nothing nothing will
kill you than staying up at night and
worrying that shit'll kill you quicker
than cancer
that should okay that that just weighs
down on your heart so once you take that
that's why when I wrote the obituary and
took my reading off it took all the
pressure off the worst thing that
happens to me is I could die but I'm not
dying I'm not going nowhere I [__] I
[__] swam in the Hudson I got my dick
sucked by a nasty chick one time with a
cold sore if I was in a sigh I was led
to died 18 years ago I lived through a
[__] yeast in
action in 1991 through a fungi toenail
lung infections if Keith Richards doing
it I'm doing it I'm going for it I don't
give a [__] and calmly wise I'm going
for it you know I was sitting here the
other day beat myself up like you guys
do at home but I [__] yeah oh yeah
and Here I am doing it myself
I'm beating myself up like I'm not doing
comedy no more I'm 15 I'm an old man
[__] that thought I'm riding this wind
out in fact I called my manager agent
last night I told him do me a favor book
me in the brain improv is a residence
I'll start on Tuesday night 20-hour
tickets just to get you [__]
out of the house gonna be like a hundred
seats tops they seat 400 how many seats
can you put in there everybody's gonna
be shut down 65 percent thing on the
lose of these showrooms between the
social space in which I'm happy about
because again even the comedy clubs got
greedy making you sit there with
somebody you don't know I don't ever
want a table with a [__] I don't
know and drink drinks that's never gonna
happen I don't care how much I like the
girl if the girl wants to blow all this
we go to a bar and I gotta sit next to
two people on the four top I don't know
I'm getting out of here like I'm getting
out of here you know comedy clubs got
their wake-up call
imagine being a time person by
themselves like me I got everybody got
their wake-up call in the words of Paul
Mooney everybody got their with [__]
wake-up call rich poor black white
Spanish this thing [__] everybody's
world up Walt Disney the Knicks JetBlue
everybody got [__] in the ass here so
do not feel bad about your stimulus
check or what's going on in your life
I'm smoking reefer like ass [__]
I know you told me yesterday of a new
saying for the pandemic what's that
reefer what's that it starts earlier now
oh yeah it starts early that starts at
what you have you and I by 12 go [__]
mother
2 o'clock is a thing of the past is the
pandemic you know plan rules change 200
milligrams at like 2 p.m. yesterday or
something to sleep there you go up Jesus
I got you a date I'm mixed
cuz I want you to get upset now Joey
keeps giving me the nighttime mix these
quickies will [__] let's let's toast
let's toast to the 45 days we should
have been having in the house it's March
[__] second I know by you [__]
I was out on March 7th to do a [__]
watching UFC and I went out another
night to do a [__] podcast I've been
in 30 [__] nights I'm done I'm ready
a bust but that doesn't mean I'm gonna
go to the park and jump up and down in
that cold water that's never gonna
[__] happen
that's not gonna happen so and it's been
a hell of a month I know you've had your
ups you down you ride outs you had a
thousand things go through your mind I
had the month the hell I got accused
like 18 things this month I got accused
of cheating on my wife no you did not
remember the night that Bert Bert was
doing a video for Tom Segura okay okay
and he [__] says I don't know what he
proposed on Twitter
I'm high as [__] my wife goes to bed I
got on Twitter about ten o'clock and
Bert post I'm looking for any porno
girls to do a video yeah so it just so
happens I follow I follow the [__]
I follow only hot wife okay was a dirty
filthy [__] animal she has videos on
them sucking dicks through holes in
walls [__] and all this [__] every time
I open up Twitter it's her [__] four
guys bouncer in Texas she's the [__]
Savage she came up to the store about
three months ago and she said hello Kate
quickly introduced it to me because she
came with one of Kate's shows in Texas
okay and Kate said she was showing the
titties at the show and driving people
crazy ham should just [__] you she makes
videos of herself like they're on
Twitter you don't have to go anywhere
they're on Twitter
The Electrician fixing something they're
playing with a [__] in the room and the
electrician is trying to fix something
he looks old brother and she's playing
with her [__] damn and the affor guys
like [__] how did I get involved in
this and then she makes him [__] suck
a dick she's nuts
so berkos do you know any poor girls
like he made a general call and I
go yeah go with Holly hot wife she's a
[__] from whom she's a Georgia Peach
and she's got the hottest [__] in Texas
not because I tasted it or not because I
knew but because look at it it's right
there in front it's getting [__] right
here oh my god I got 20 things my wife
got hit up on Facebook now yeah so by
you by random Twitter people [__] that
you've been waiting for girls for years
because listen it's like the chubby girl
wants that way Jamie I love Jamie you
know why I love Jamie you know I blew
Jamie up
i'ma tell you why I blew jamia because
two days out bless you
there's another one there for you that
was empty hey god that's pretty actually
I blew up Jamie because there was there
were so many girls for a couple days
that we just asked him for money
right did you see though the only fans
of canceled stuff not even the only fans
from oh yeah Big Mo didn't move from my
car and I'm the type of dude I hope
anybody but I'm like do X I want the
most from my bum quarter yeah it's um if
there's two bums and I'm gonna get one
of them Accor that I want one of them to
have a talent dance jump right here on
fire what's up I want the most out of my
bum dollar now am I looking for a girl
to show my hell [__] you know me you
want to show me that little battle life
I'm not gonna look away like I like the
louis c.k girls if they look at this
dick through their fingers right I'm not
gonna do that but I'm gonna look at it
but I'm not gonna you know look insight
used for that so here's this girl from
my close by that comes to the comedy
store begging for money she's like a
[__] 7 she's cute and I look at Jamie
who's got a really pretty face he's just
a little bigger than most girls but
she's voluptuous she's got a great ass
and she's out there doing the videos
she's not showing it does she just stand
up ten minutes topless but she won't
show a [__] she won't show her ass a
guy like me respects that yeah a guy
like me says you know what his a
[__] that's husband she's not
sluttin she's hustling and people were
super you don't even want to know how
much money she's been good for her and
thank God
god bless it yeah but she's not showing
a [__] she's very decent she's not
showing a [__] she's showing her
titties
you know what Teddy's like me show me
your balls you see it you seen one said
you see them all
I guess but I think her mom is anonymous
you go deep into that monkey you show me
a little bell that's completely [__]
of difference now you were [__] dirty
Adam okay fair enough
but but it wasn't about that it was just
like the fact that you mentioned Holly
hot wife and what we're doing I'm gonna
have it what did they say people like
Joey we listened to the podcast we don't
know you cheat on your wife who said
anything about cheating and then I
learned a lot about broadcast I've
learned a lot about media I learned a
lot about turning people's words around
yeah recently I've learned a lot about
just you know I don't have a listen you
guys know my my book is an open [__]
heart at this point I don't give a [__]
it's out there the stories are out there
you want to hear them I like these
messages I got on Facebook Joey can you
tell me a little bit about yourself
going on the podcast then they'll call
back go I just listen to the one with
ray go when you put the garbage bricks
in the thing so what do you want to know
about my life that's the type of diet
right you know no it's uh it's a scare
that's scary that's always let's not
worry about twister words in today's
Internet is a nightmare but it's not
just the internet it's reporters have
been doing it for years they turn the
tone of something around I didn't turn
it as a tone that I had slept with her
it no no I never said that my tone was
look at her she's a hot piece ass you
can see her videos on there all the time
when I step up for Jamie
I'll call Jamie right here in front of
you right now and ask her Jamie I've
ever gotten freshly yeah I don't want to
see a [__] I applaud what she's doing
because she's not staying at home
waiting for a [__] hand up that's
never gonna come and I love it
especially like it would be so out of
character for you now I'm just here on
your wife
who we've had on the podcast but then
b22 like put it out there online like if
I had anyone who I'd like who would be
good at keeping a secret but I think Joe
I think Joe would be pretty good 500
stories I tell but I got a thousand I
can't down right dad you know now that I
got this deal with audio boom with the
audiobook right I'm gonna tell those
stories
oh yeah I have to cut them down a little
bit I can't say the names I have no more
stories that you could have and this
this situation the last couple of weeks
me being quarantined and be going to
places in my mind where I haven't been
trust me guys to get out of this [__]
anxiety I have one I'm doing it the only
way they reward myself is to write this
down and give it the in the audio book
because I'm gonna give you real feelings
of what I went through at that time
remember I've been to prison and I'm an
only child
quarantine doesn't affect me like it
affects other people right I could have
you know I can have a thing going on in
my mind like I've done everything that I
sat off to do this break
I still haven't cleaned the bookshelf
yet but everything else pretty much I
want to clean that notebook screw away
no books looked at material got rid of
it on the computer
I wasn't creative there was no
creativity out of me in March the
creativity didn't start coming out of me
to about April 18th that's what I could
really feel it I've fallen a lot better
I went back on the Alpha brain you know
I hadn't been on alpha brain on like
three or four months
I went back on the Alpha brain and I
really started writing and I really
started looking at the silver lining and
I found it I found it with the audio
boom you know I put my summer together
my plan was right now we'll go off for
the survival today what are we gonna do
today
okay what's gonna happen in 30 days from
now mayor Garcetti is gonna
fifteen more day the governor Newsom is
gonna announce 15 more days for us and
for New York that puts us at June
[__] first Texas is already opening
up some calmly closed May 27th - Ville
is not allowing live entertainment they
are open the restaurants are open and so
right off the bat so we all have to wait
before they make moves and this just has
not to do with comedy this applies to
you guys you guys know what I'm talking
about
that you don't really know what's gonna
happen are you gonna go back to your
office are they gonna take happy is and
put you in the office do you see what
new office has anybody see 60 minutes
and see what the new office is it gonna
look like how you gonna sit down in
office you can only walk on one
direction there's gonna be arrows on the
floor really telling you what direction
you're going we all have to be prepared
for this happy is do you really have to
go into work no okay then do everything
from home oh we need those files well
download we don't even go to file isn't
anymore like old files now it's all
online so all these things are gonna
happen so be prepared for me talking
about you know there's people were at
home struggling working at home
yeah it's art they've never had somebody
not being over there back it was I'm
still not great at it I'm better than
when I started five six years ago but
it's it's a definite skill cuz you go in
and you other people you don't want to
look be the one guy like looking at your
phone so being at home just by yourself
was hard I can't imagine being home with
a family or a roommate it's a what in
quarantine yeah this has taught me to
love my wife again I found not that I
didn't love her but I fall in love with
her when you go through something
together with another human being
whether you know it let's say two
roommates let's say you were roommates
with a person right now that you did not
give them or that you were about to
evict right before this pandemic app and
now you have to stand within two months
and now you got to see the difference I
him and he got to see the different side
of you and you actually like each other
and you've had to talk to each other I
know for a fact things like that have
happened I know for a fact that some men
that's why there's no alcohol in my
house some men and women have a couple
beers you know this financial stresses
and one of them says you know we
shouldn't quit that job all now this is
my fault I was supposed to know that
[__] Wu Han was gonna release the flu
in [__] February you know so there's
animosity right now going in homes in my
world everything is forgiven
during this pandemic everything is
[__] forgiven let's try to do the
best we can
I'm not gonna lie to you I'm a father a
husband just like you guys and listening
to podcast taught me the first two weeks
look me in the [__] eye and tell me
the first two weeks you didn't think
you're gonna stab your wife remember
that second week when you were sitting
at home and often you are on the
computer you like domestic violence is
up and you're like man man and all of a
sudden something happened you started
talking to your wife or your girlfriend
and you saw that side of her that we
took for granted for a long time because
this is what all this is about
the things we've taken for granted for
the longest time how easy it was for us
to order grub up and you ought to grub
up a couple times I've slept recently
okay so you know this is what I'm saying
to people this is also gonna teach you
what you can live with that yeah this is
also gonna let you know what you can
live without you were paying 215 then go
to that club every month now you're
doing the work at home you're doing it
better you feel better maybe I'll save
the 215 dollars there's nothing better
than finding out the things you can live
without that's always fantastic finding
out what you can live without mostly you
like [__] that I'll never do it again
you know well I didn't do coke for 28
days and also in one day I said well I
haven't done coke for 28 days I'm gonna
go get some coke I'm like really do I
really want to go get
goke no i don't I already got 28 days
yeah I mean IIIi cooked I think for over
a month straight so my credit card bills
are way down you look at other stuff
like the stores that are closed like oh
do we really need that store or do I
really like don't really need to go to
the mall and buy a new DVD this week you
know all those palm readers are closed
in Hollywood yeah how many people gonna
go to a palm reader nobody saw this yeah
who went into a palm read and the guy
said listen to in six months I see a
woman whatever come in and [__]
destroy America nobody called this so
all those [__] fortune tellers are
out of business
burglars they're having a hard time
burglars they're even filing foreheads
so funny burgers you know how I know cuz
I walk around now in the daytime and I
mean if I was a burglar looking for a
house everybody's home everybody's home
[__] burglars the filing for
unemployment and they're allowed them
they'll give it to your [__] as long
as you're not robbing houses will give
you unemployment whatever the [__] you
want
that's wild burglars are in bad business
right now but car break-ins are up
please lock your cars
don't put change in your car don't leave
a dollar bill in the circle of the car
they'll break a window to get a dollar
and it's gonna cost you a 500 adoptable
don't leave change in your front seat
don't leave bags in your car don't be
that [__] stupid if they want to
break into the car for water they're
gonna get water it's a manual and a
registration that said you break into my
car there's nothing there's batteries
for my earplugs for my hearing aids and
there's a lighter in there in case I
need to smoke a joint on the road you
know yeah there's no witness of my car
pound the we didn't I got nothing huh
no I got nothing in there now this has
been a very very interesting month and
I'm happy you guys made it true that's
it do you think they have like
telephones for the for the criminals
that they help each other out
we move one way okay nobody else each
other believe these comedians to
telephone us they're still waiting to
pay the [__] rent that's true you
know I'm saying they're still paying the
[__] well they're way
pay their rent so nobody knows when the
money's coming that's why I advise
everybody to take it that gets back
can't through the [__] money now you
can't get your ticket back for no
concerts Kenya right now they're saying
well they haven't cancelled yet well
eighteen people walking around here with
[__] masks around they can't breathe
what do you think everything that people
gotta fly down the far they go see you
on June 18th so now you don't have no
money I told you eight weeks ago get
your money back from any show you can
you don't give a [__] when they come
around again you go see him because now
they're gonna hold up the money that to
make it as much interest in day as they
can on your [__] money how stupid can
you be
here's to you Lee saying this I at made
a serious commitment with Steve Simone
they've been walking yeah doing
kettlebells next time you see Lee he'll
look like a [__] x-ray you understand
me I'd be nice you know it's been tough
but it's been good it's a at least try
to make something positive commander
less fruity patooty no it's nice the
grapefruit
I like that I've been telling you
everybody this that there is a silver
lining to this you know what man guess
what else gonna happen guess what else
could happen you're gonna realize that
that woman you've been married to for
ten years or that guy you've been gay
with three years that his behavior
during all this is unacceptable you know
the divorce this is gonna open up doors
for people that have [__] been closed
for years because this has been the
first time you ever had to think I felt
really happy anyone's getting divorced
but they were they were joking online
yesterday because Jay Cutler the old
Chicago Bears quarterback just retired
two years ago and then got stuck with
his wife for three weeks in Bermuda on
quarantine and they just in that they
just literally just filed for divorce
yeah because you get to see that
person's colors this opens up your eyes
this gives you focus
this lets you notice the people around
you we thought were your friends you're
gonna find out who your friends are
you're gonna find out who your friends
aren't are you're gonna find out a lot
of things that were scary this is and
what do I tell people especially men
the number one thing that destroys men
thinking when you overthink something
they ain't nothing to think about action
is the movement you know I had a a weird
month also because I had other [__]
going on under the background beside the
accusations are doing everything else a
situation happening me years ago I don't
know if we talked about the podcast but
I really wanted to give it light about
the girl checked me at my show in New
York they talked about on the podcast
briefly yeah you said that
you mentioned someone they maybe should
have mentioned yeah and then that she'd
passed away mm-hmm you know and it was
weird because I told you guys so the
girl came to my show and then after the
show she took my number randomly and she
says I'll be in touch with you when I
come to California and it's just this is
gonna be so weird she called me and said
that you know who the [__] was I the
parade into New York and New Jersey to
do comedy with at least coming into and
apologizing to some of the people I
needed to apologize to she goes you
don't need to apologize to everybody
some of them were scumbags on their own
but you do need to apologize to these
couple people it was like six people and
I [__] apologized to three of them
like a man I contacted them and I felt
that the other three people it's like
when you go to AAA I think one of the
steps is I think step number four is
making amends to everybody that you've
hurt you know and I'll tell you anybody
I talked to from that program I always
asked me did you make amends and
everybody in there go close to everybody
you know why because there's some people
that will never get it there's some
people that you went I have an aunt in
Miami years ago I went and went down
there to pick up some stuff at taking
2014 and I thought about visiting that
and she's in an old lady's home and I
made a few calls
and when I called the Sun to see where
she was at he goes why he's thinking
he's going over there and I was like I
don't know maybe I'll send some flowers
or something he goes I don't know how
it's gonna work out
and even though I was gonna go over
there sometimes guys you gotta let that
goes live because there's some people
that you're gonna go and apologize to
and it's just a reason for them to go on
into a different war with you the three
people that didn't accept my apology
accepted just how I thought they were
and since I told you the story
one of them has reached out to me during
this whole thing and we've spoken about
three times
and nothing has come up he was happy
that was back in his life so you know
sometimes you don't have to apologize to
everybody I don't ever want you to think
that because these three people that she
expect me to apologize to I really want
to apologize to them but there was so
much history in the air that we're gonna
have to address one of those things and
that's where this thing is gonna go so
you can't make every situation golden
you know you just can't do it even this
situation like I told you this this
quarantine what's going on the last
[__] six weeks you know some people
have gotten good things out of this the
underlying stuff you know I got to spend
time my family I got to see Mercy's
weaknesses I you know me and my wife
working out perfectly where I go when
she goes out she goes in I go out we're
never really that much together so we
don't get sick of each other but all in
all I love my wife and Lois but that's
not the point the point is I just didn't
feel I should apologize and one of the
guys I made apologies to that he
deserved my apology you know he called
back he never called me back after I
apologized to him but then he called me
back one day
to apologize to me and he said you know
I after you apologized to me I was still
mad at you but it took my father dying
and for me to experience the pain to
understand what you were going through
and why you did that to me at that age
well good he goes now I understood where
your motivation came from you had luck
just lost your mother and you couldn't
focus
so that's even happened so he was a
Sarasota Florida and my a'ight now I
would talk every two or three [__]
days do you think there's a possibility
like one of those people who you don't
think you should apologize to someone
can happen and live in the upcoming
years and maybe you guys will talk like
it's not something set in stone but one
of the people that I was supposed to
apologize past okay at the time they
were a little older and I sent flowers
card I put you know I always loved it
and their grandmother came out and their
granddaughter she reached out and
thanked me for the kind flowers the note
bah bah bah bah you know but I mean
there was still two people on that list
that day and you know what I see him on
Facebook all the time
and they see me on Facebook and they
don't say much and I don't say much the
guy has made one remark in the last 10
years
you guys take stuff seriously not my get
sarcastic remark okay 10 years he made a
sarcastic remark and I could unload on
him but I'm older now and I said what's
the what's the use
he's always gonna be the same person
that's why I don't want to apologize to
him but because he has 19 different
recently the beef I thought he had with
me well I did talk to him one time there
was a complete different beef he was mad
because he said when I did interviews I
never mentioned his name I mentioned his
brother's name
so did your the sanitized alien like
well had an interviews for the local
papers when he got mad and because I
didn't mention his name I mentioned his
brother's name because I always know I
was a war with him you know really and
not really when I say war I mean there's
no war we haven't spoken in 30 years
right but even if you have how many
people are you supposed to mention
that's kind of crazy
it's it doesn't matter I mean people are
gonna be people I'm just talking about
when it comes to apologies how they work
out now they banned themselves out and
you know what you you [__] with some
people and some people don't want an
apology like they're like listen I'm
moving on you know I have a couple
friends that have moved on from me am i
ashamed to say that no not at all one
day they look at me took a look at the
whole picture and I in fact there's one
guy that told me to my [__] face when
I called them and guess what that call
was or was about 17 years ago his
brother commits called me about a month
ago me and his brother have always been
great friends were friends since we were
kids
my friend just went into a tailspin and
he thought I was responsible for one of
the proms he had grown up well have to
do that though you're listen I don't
want your mind like that that's a
reasonable thing you can say that's a
morning I wish I was strong enough to
say that when he told me I was not mad I
was not angry and I understood I did not
tell him to go [__] himself he wished me
good luck
I wished him good luck and I got it yeah
so I got it it was too much it was too
much that the the years of our
friendship were just too much it was it
was and it was a it was a five year run
that it was everything every element it
had it was like what's that movie with
Adam Sandler watch one well the one you
get shot in the [__] head uncut gems
right that's what it was me and him one
cut gem two types of guy so every day I
still remember driving with him once a
week two
a doctor to get faint trach muscle
relaxants for his fake back injury
whether we were in kids you actually
take pills they would give him what
muscle relax okay he would go to the
doctor the doctor cuts his back there
you go doc it feels like eight more
weeks so he got a job at a big [__]
plant he was a kid right and every
summer he would hurt herself to have the
summer off and it would be paid so lazy
he would get eighteen hundred a month
from unemployment or disability whatever
and he would live his life like a doctor
and then like October football season
his back would be back to long he did
this every year for years I love it for
years he I had a bad back so the one
year I hung out with him when he really
ran the scam the one summer we went out
to get pills once a week we used to go
to I forget the name of the town it's
next to corn in New Jersey they had a
great Chinese restaurant there with an
all-you-can-eat Monday nights and they
served shrimp and lobster sauce we used
to go in and take all the shrimp lobster
sauce Chinese guy would lose his
forelock collide we would take all the
[__] shrimp pie it was not Leonia
there was a different town if I ask
Timmy Holloway he remembered because
he's the one that gave me the restaurant
but yeah I listen that people change but
if I have two dear friends that will not
talk to me I have one guy that me and
him say something to ourselves on
Facebook he's not I apologized to him
years ago I apologized to him years ago
he's just still kept me at arm's
distance because of his ownself
insecurities he's got problems and they
don't want me to know about it so how do
you and I guess it's different for every
person obviously but you're talking
about making the decision to apologize
to some people and not to others well
how do you make that decision like what
do you want what makes you choose a
person to the positive I have to think
about what happened and I got to taste
them during the [__] quarantine I
thought about a couple of things a
couple of nights and I'm surprised a lot
more people still talk to me my Dino's
and like
a couple nights I beat myself up every
duty during this quarantine just because
I thought of things late night then I'd
forgotten about you know I always say
that you gotta check on your skeletons
in the closet from time to time if not
they're gonna check on you I guess oh
Jesus so I had a [__] Jin you know I had
a little nervous break ins you know when
I was uh 12 I dated a girl and we broke
up one day she fell off a bike she fell
off my bike I've told this story I just
found a feeling guilt about that because
in her mind today she thinks I did it on
purpose
if you know anything about me I would
never do anything like that
that's not my that's not my belt I don't
if I want to do something I'll do it to
your face you know there were little
things at night that I just tripped on
you know when I was 18 I had a kid in
the head with a Heineken bottle he was a
lot older than I was and he had an axe
hand while he was gonna hit a friend of
mine what did you want me to do but I
felt bad how the whole thing went down
that's why I'm really hoping that out of
my friends that called Louie ghastly no
calls because his mother was the court
clerk when that went down so I hit him
in the head on a Sunday night and I we
ran away there was 10 guys in the car
and we ran away but it gets the pizza
guys ow what's the ID'd us and they came
the next day and then the rest me they
gave me a summons nice they go to court
for a salt its reefer smoking days
[__] it's Wednesday sparked him if
you gotta meet I'm saying like the motto
says if you ain't high by lunchtime go
stab your mother in the neck and pull
out the I'm drama the tube I don't even
know what drama is I'm just dropping
words he out of respect anyway what we
talking about about bringing apologies
oh stuff you did like it was oh yeah
well as people who don't like you like
that you feeling bad about stuff I was
feeling bad about that story I felt bad
about [__] having a roommate one time
when I left the Colorado I just left him
a note and some cash
I loved the heart to tell him to his
face that I was going to Colorado that's
the guy that won't talk you know he
really got hurt by that we were we were
way better friends for me to do that I
was just so scared of telling him I knew
he would be mad at me and that comes in
the long run who's gonna be mad at me no
matter what these are the things you
learned from your youth you know right
so now listen everybody knows my
situation I married them I got a kid I
don't fit in windows no more I don't
Berg I haven't burglarized in 20 [__]
years from time to time I shoplift a
lighter by mistake they think I'd get
out of it thank God I got a water
fertilizer it wasn't I didn't get out
anything Tommy took over
Tommy saved my life the More war effort
I put into Tommy the more my life got
[__] saved you know so this was a
great combination I'm very fortunate to
be here but but you [__] just
remember some of you states I get
another 30 days tacked on and listen
we already did 45 what's another 30 you
know I'm saying as long as you get your
benefits as long as unemployment listen
I'm hearing pro and con whatever I'm
hearing pro and con but you know what
you're gonna make it you already made it
45 days the worst of the [__] thing
is over with we did it we did it [__]
together I did the podcast with the
[__] mask on eight they weren't the
podcast the best podcast they weren't
the people you wanted to see but I took
your mind off the [__] coronavirus
for a [__] hour just by sitting here
talking [__] even if we talked about the
[__] on a virus and when I showed you
my nutsack last week South America
everybody forgot about that coronavirus
[__] an hour that night so please my
goal since day one has been come lesson
this [__] pain whether to wait
laughter what
[__] just educating ourselves about
anxiety fear what's really going on you
know I've gotten I got emails from
people from all over and people tell me
what's going on their community that
they only have three cases you know [__]
like this this is all parties hear other
people talk about stuff you're going
through this is all I tried to do here
from day one was just to keep it
together I remember telling Lee we're
gonna keep doing the pockets he's like
really I'm again we're not stopping this
is people gonna need this more than
[__] ever just and how would it take
that [__] mind away you know but the
person I talked about on Joe's podcast
that got mad at me was that girl that
used to sit on Budweiser bottles in high
school mmm
and she passed away last week from the
Colvin I know she was about 61 and one
night I was on Rogan and I told the
story a couple times about this ball we
went through his kids and [__] she
sat on the Galliano bottle and all this
[__] and [__] the girl who called me
out said that she also had an apology
coming from me and I looked a brother up
on Facebook I couldn't find them I
couldn't find anybody no no I I think I
was spelling the last name along or
something and then last on that on that
that that girl died without me
apologizing so I was two people I really
wanted to apologize to that past both of
them one of them I had access to I was
just waiting to go home to go down to
downtown North Bergen and knock on a
door like a man I wasn't gonna do it on
the phone I had a knocking at door
everybody I apologize to I knocked on
that door well yeah I knocked on your
door why [__] call that's [__] [__]
you know he's not out of the blue on
that door yeah holy Sh what does that
feel like two of the people I didn't
talk to my 20 years over 20 years
there's still one more person that I
have to knock on that door and it's been
since
1894 we haven't spoke over an argument
well okay what's it women thing with the
argument was over two hundred [__]
dollars really a hundred dollars and I
thought about that during that that we
were together for five years I was
together with this couple every
Wednesday night they were my Savior they
bought me dinner on Wednesday nights and
I mean we were tight friends when she
could before before she got pregnant the
first time
she was upset because I had already
gotten married and had a child in
Colorado and she told me how come I
can't have a kid and we were talking on
the phone I go stop smoking cigarettes
and she stopped smoking cigarettes and
she got knocked up within a month oh
really that's Addie it was crazy so we
were always tight friends and then one
day it was just a bad communication
about money you know she was there when
I robbed the jewelry store I sold her
some of the chains and the jewelry store
were always friends there was never a
problem with us a little one [__] day
I was doing something and she offered
money and I said absolutely and then six
months later she called back for it and
I was blown away I was like who does
that but I didn't raise my hand they
came to me in a spot when I needed it
they sent me the money but when she
asked me for the 200 back it rattled my
cage a little bit so I hung out with her
and a boyfriend at the time husband so
what I did was every time I saw the
boyfriend I give him a twenty dollar bag
of weed and said take it off the bill
and after about six or seven times I
came back to Colorado and I didn't you
know I didn't know when I was leaving
New Jersey so like I used to see him on
the weekends only because everybody had
a job in 93 right I was doing comedy
during the week on the weekends I would
see him cuz I was in the headline
so one day I'm in Colorado and my
[__] ex-wife calls me and she's a guy
just got a call from such-and-such she
says you owe or $100 still I'm whatever
you're embarrassed and that is to me for
somebody to say I owe them money
like I [__] hate that [__] yeah
especially close one if it drives me
crazy so me thinking that I know this
person says we were kids for them to
call my ex-wife and throw and put me in
the situation them knowing what I'm
going through with my ex-wife and now
you gonna throw me a little bust my
ex-wife I figured now I can't talk to
you anymore
so I went I put together took me two or
three days I put together a money order
I didn't even put a letter in there I
just put a money order 400 bucks Mel the
tub never spoke to them again at about
eight years ago the girl reached out on
Facebook and I thought and I didn't even
think right I just erased a friend
request or whatever the [__] that was
and I wasn't that's how mad I get yeah I
wasn't even thinking about it and just
what now I want to apologize to them and
she's off Facebook cuz she's got like
six kids she ended up having like six
[__] kids that's crazy I mean it
happens everybody ever like people drift
apart but to have a fight dog on this is
why this is what this time period lets
you do good let's just think about the
stupid [__] you did maybe call a friend
or two I've called a lot of people over
this quarantine people that haven't
talked to in years just to check in and
catch up with them you got nothing but
time you got no place to be you might as
well open up to a relationship with them
and see what's going on with them I'm
gonna call my parents more often to
check in but come on stuff to say fine
yeah like before they keep me out for
like hours and now they but yeah we've
I discovered it now well you know when
you call somebody today if you call
anybody today and check in with them the
first 16 seconds 16 minutes of the
conversation obviously they're gonna be
about the coronavirus because that's
what's in front of you right now
but after you settle down and you start
talking like me and my friends talk all
the [__] time
what's gotten me out of this mind was
that I've spoken to more my friends from
Jersey now who I do on the usual and now
we've opened up that relationship again
that is why I figured it's time to bring
my friends into the podcast look it's
been too long you know and I'm not
talking about like Dani B or whatever
I'm bringing a spectrum into you guys
I'm bringing in a guy that's a musician
that him and I grew up with what the C
Pink Floyd together we're gonna tell you
stories about getting together at night
and find $20 worth the weed and get 27
joints smoking them all but just you
know and then H going home with one
joint so that means we smoked 22 joints
between five of us I mean we we were
kids together I got another guy I'm
gonna call that was another very special
friend of mine he was a little older but
he was in my sophomore homeroom and he
was just a blast
I saw him told teachers to go [__]
themselves
I seen him do some crazy stuff I'm sure
we'll cover it and we're gonna have my
brother on my brothers gonna talk to you
guys about when I used to make Rob gas
stations and make him pick me up and he
wouldn't even know he was picking me up
because I was robbing the gas - how
would you feel me if I just said pick me
up and front of the [__] the Cuban
joins Burbank at 4:30 and you're like
where's the sandwiches just step on the
car go why why why what's going on
I just robbed them why did you rob them
and get in my car cause if I would've
told you I was gonna rob you wouldn't
show up little coupons so I had a trick
everybody so he's the guy I had a trick
and I'm trying to get Louis cast lino
and it was gonna be interesting cuz his
brother his uncle
was the guy that they hung in they gotta
pay choked and [__] that movie on HBO
with everybody with all the mobsters oh
yeah what's his name I need to be or
Netflix Netflix about the [__] yeah
well Irishman the Irishman
he's as uncle was the guy who Tony bow
choked in the car my mother died I
killed and then there that's who his
uncle is but Louie cast lino has got
stories of us come on to see ac/dc on
acid going to the movie theatres on acid
and he's buck wild but I know he works
nights so I gotta catch him in between
sleeping snorting getting his dick
sucked and going through his warehouse
it's kind of [__] tough so it's gonna
be tough but we're gonna try these
things because yeah this disc Warren
teen we had some [__] tremendous
guest set up had David Provo coming in
from Mean Streets The Sopranos
I had the [__] guy who was gonna play
who played Connie's wife and the husband
and the Godfather who Sonny beat him up
he was coming out cuz he was doing a
project with victim they come on the
longest I had a tremendous musician who
now I I don't know if I can reschedule
him cuz he's back in [__] Chicago I
had him coming on but this coronavirus
ruined a lot of things a lot of people
I'm just fortunate that I could still
get through to you guys as you could
tell I'm not selling comedy dates I'm
not doing nothing I just want you guys
to know do you have a voice then you
have somewhere to [__] go to people
were going through the same [__]
thing as you are we're not no better we
all put up and someone like at a [__]
time you know what there's parts of the
day I feel like [__] driving the car
off a cliff but I closed my eyes and I
think about prison and I think about
confinement and I think about what I
could do with my day to break up the
[__] day okay today's Tuesday I'm
definitely jerking off eight times
I just got a pic what time and put it on
the schedule so I know what I'm living
for oh should I have this steak no I got
a jerk-off in 10 minutes I don't want a
jerk-off for the steak in my stomach cuz
I might have a [__] heart attack so
these are all the things that happen
during a quarantine you know I hope what
I really a quarantine when you're in
[__] prison this is what happens you
gotta you revolve you there I'm
masturbation you yeah you got a schedule
in like a bang without a lady in the
shower I'm banging another without 1130
take a nap I'll eat something bang
another one out go to the kitchen to eat
something bang another one out and then
you know you got a bang cool them up
before you go to bed nothing comes out
of your nutsack it's just pure [__]
air by that point you're just jiggling
around like a [__] and you [__]
pass out but my point is this has been
completely different
you got notebooks you have computers you
have a room you could do jumping jacks
to sit ups on if you haven't taken care
of what the [__] you have to take care
of this is on you [__] you've had six
weeks now for what were you
[__] you got two weeks left
whatever you plan on doing do it please
just do it just [__] do it what's the
big [__] deal
all right get it on would so you can
move on back to work and no [__]
skeletons in your closet so you
[__] I got another 30 days in
seclusion like huncle Joey and you know
who you are
Jersey you're not going nowhere you
[__] are contaminated to the
end of time New York City you're dead
if you live in New York right now just
take a look at that wall and go Jesus
Christ I'm up to paint that [__]
patches that's not going nowhere you
know I mean there's just parts of the
country that you got to accept it nobody
died in Louisiana today I think that was
the first day that nobody punched a
ticket thank God you know I don't know
what's going on anywhere I just know
that here I'm social distancing I'm
washing my hands more than the [__]
you know the chiclet gives hand jobs for
a living
I hope they wash their hands because
some of us check
go from a hand job to hand job you might
as well go rub dicks in the Cub Scouts
it's like being the Cub Scouts you rub
your dick let the other Cub Scout said
look then they play bigger boo the
[__] leave this sexy weather as the
warmest dick I don't know I got thrown
out that comes cuz I didn't want to be
there anyway with those [__] nerd
[__] communist I lasted like three
meetings with those [__] homos and I
said I gotta get the [__] out of here so
anyway my point is whatever you got left
to do do it you got two weeks me I got a
month I got a month to prepare my book
I can't wait to [__] lay it down now
it's a new perspective and I knew this
it's like the reason why we didn't write
[__] calmly I'd have no perspective
the only perspective I had that was
stuck in the house and I had done all
these bad things all my life sure I was
[__] down on myself I fired the
nervous breakdown now I'm back [__]
and a lot of you guys whatever pay we
kept showing up what would I tell you
with the church we keep showing up
they're not gonna be the best podcast
they're not gonna be the guests you want
to [__] see but guess what I stuck to
my word
I kept showing up that's it you did your
[__] 45 days now you got another 15
for a good time or you're off whatever
you decide on tell people to stay the
[__] away from me things you don't
really know what this really it really
is
remember one thing like I've been
telling every [__] podcast Disney is
not opening back up so before you go
plan that trip with six people with six
midgets and a bus that you were planning
to see oh we're gonna go to Lake Havasu
before you plan all that [__] think
about Disney not opening up I'm thinking
about your safety I'm thinking about
your help I'm thinking about my help
like I said I'm trying to get this this
little thing going on at Brea I'm gonna
keep my ticket prices low see you guys
to come out I'll be there every over the
Tuesday you know I'm not fly no one if
you love me if you're my [__] nephew
you don't want me fine look at me
and I'm trying to lose weight I'm trying
to drink what I do every day I do
everything I'm supposed to do I'm
[__] sleeping you know I smoked today
for the first time because I'm about a
Japanese really join month yeah I had to
smoke with you guys I'm sorry that I've
been a little weak in that department
lately look at that the [__] thing
was still smoking there's what I'm
talking about we don't stop here we go
724 [__] if you're doing it I'm
doing I don't give a [__] and that's it
I hope you made it through this
quarantine so far you did you're 60 days
so if you got a DUI 999 you feel so now
you're sitting there going man I didn't
want to go to jail for DUI but [__] it I
can't do this standing on my head like
that black before Joey just think about
it 60 days I take you this 45 days you
didn't think you're gonna come out of
this you thought you were gonna dive
look you're here from now on do me a
favor wake up look up and say God thank
you for giving me another day at least I
got the opportunity to [__] somebody in
the ass whether I do or whether he comes
out of a bush and sucks my dick I don't
know but at least I'm awake stop [__]
feeling bad for yourself and stop it you
know we think this cold big
[__] you ever see when these
Cobras [__] get rolled out of a
hospital there's a black guy with a
trumpet like you know celebrating that
guy don't know he hasn't been to hell
yet wait three against the hospital bill
wait till the bills start popping out
wait do you see those Yahoo ads with
people going one month at do it my coded
bills on 18 they stay 22 million [__]
dollars so get ready for all that this
is gonna come on levels just worry about
your health your mental being pay what
you can tell the landlord to suck your
dick listen listen cheeseburgers with
five guys you and that ugly Jew brother
of yours both these could go [__]
yourselves I'm not paying rent you want
to evict me give it a holler good good
I'll burn the [__] building down and
the share
gonna come that way we're in the
building room maybe you if you [__]
push my buttons I'll [__] light this
thing up on the fire like like [__]
you know me I don't give a [__]
there you go - go - what's that not
anything is on fire that's all we should
go - when in doubt while on fire oh my
god button
[__] put some bleach in there kill
the DNA what are you [__]
I've been lighting things on fire for
years oh you don't want to find the
condom light on fire if you do something
bad I'm not saying I did something bad
but I had a friend of mine taught me
cheated Leedy I go what'd he do with the
condoms because I throw them in the
toilet she throws them away
don't you ever let it throw it away that
should go [__] save that condom spray
that juice in a [__] in the next thing
are you [__] all only 2000 a month
yeah they're dirty [__] out
there you throw your own condom away you
don't even throw it away you take it out
to go you don't even know it's in your
little side pocket and then when you get
out you squirt it into the [__] sewer
you give us some rats some of you come
and you like that condom on fire that's
what I would do if I was to do something
evil but I don't do nothing me why stay
home every [__] night
dislike hojae when he killed his wife if
I did it if I was gonna do it you take
those condoms on me you light them on
fire
nobody's gonna find those things there's
no DNA anywhere you can't give them a
fuss stabbing in the hotel you gotta
give them a standing outside in the park
or something
so the DNA falls on the glass and then
punch her in the back so comes out of a
[__] monkey so there's no leftovers
in her underwear that's how they get you
I don't [__] know listen it's the
church what's happened now we're just
[__] around here what I'm trying to
say to you is we did it congratulations
we'll see you [__] Monday
morning all right you did it you went
through the toughest buy this whole
[__] thing it's over forty five
[__] days you put in the house
if you've been in the house since March
14th think you've been in the house
since March 13th
think about it what what the what else
do I want from you I just wanted you to
stay healthy and the [__] in that that's
it so now you did 60-day now you know
how it feels when you do 60 [__] days
in jail well it makes it a 10-year
sentence and 15 days of good time you
watched all your dishes you didn't get
quite the suck knowing Mick is dick
Oh nobody's gonna write you love letters
from the county jail and that's it you
just did 60 days congratulate yourself
you made it to my okie Spooky's to my
little anguses to my JB Shetty's the
[__] that Deborah hub stir if she
don't have Colvin nobody's got it
alright if Deborah Harbor still don't
got covered she's a male lady she
[__] nice the dogs up in Boston even
the dogs got [__] and was there what's
the dogs they got [__] kovat Boston
is bad so I'm I'm happy to see all you
guys Scott Cunningham I'm happy to see
the whole church family Joey by Maurice
your Alvarado my boy up in Ottawa
[__] the little kid everybody's alive
we made it through and we're gonna keep
punching Monday more than 6:00 a.m.
again I'm very excited about this
morning's podcast they've been a little
scattered and whatnot you know me I'm
best when I'm Jesus coming back from the
grave that's when I do my best work
I'll see you [__] Monday
morning tip-top Magoo ready to go have a
great weekend Lee kick this [__]
meal
[Applause]
[Music]